I got my first tattoo when I was 14
right here my lord
John 3:16 I was excited the fact that I
was about to get a tattoo without okay
okay my period from like when I was
fourteen seventeen and I was really like
patent crazy in my life and I would like
wouldn't he probably go like twice a
week it was one summer I probably got my
whole like stomach down neck like I just
went oh David because I was so addicted
to it I was younger like like they
didn't I feel like they really didn't
hurt as much
but like the older I get I'm just like I
got that one out like 16 now hurt like a
[ __ ] to it really I really lose the
pain after I heard it like I don't know
how to describe the pain but after
definitely I really don't have any
favorite tattoo it was crazy like when I
look at him it's like kind of time out
of my life the big knobs had to I really
started like tapping into like my Asian
background of stuff my mom was born
there going
more and then she later moved here jack
of our nightmare before christmas I got
this one I was like 16 one of my
favorite movies when I was growing up
I've seen it so many years upside down
and I've never seen it hi looks you know
ready because I'm always used to look at
it like this it's just crazy I got these
when I was 15 it was like my label when
I was young it was like my first quiet
that I had its standard for getting
every dollar in educated av I always
needed a fait stamp but I didn't want to
like do nothing I thought I was gonna
optimize look too much no like I don't
even like notice that's it anymore which
is crazy
[Music]
ghetto tattoos and I have like good work
you know so it's a mixture of everything
so I think it just depends on what I'm
on at the moment you know I'm saying
like everything I'm doing right now it's
asian-inspired like the last year I've
been working on a lot of asian-inspired
kind of stuff that's why I got like the
dragon there like few years ago I was
really into like the Egyptian culture
studying that stuff some Sphynx here the
Eye of Horus here on my stomach so you
know just depends on what I'm really
into at the moment I kind of let the
artists do what they they do first I'll
have a vision in my eye see what the
artist comes up with and everything like
cuz I have an author from there cuz like
I feel like when you go to a tattoo
artist you're going to that person for
their kind of work you always kind of
want to like give them their room to
like be the artist first and then you
give your opinion yeah I think any
advice that I can give to somewhere that
wants to get a tattoo it's always good
to get something that you know be there
forever
can't believe family names their kid
names whatever relates you know whatever
really speaks to you you know
kind of going into tacky shop like hey
let me get this oh this is cool
like it's cool sometimes we do stuff
like that but you got to also know that
it's gonna be there forever